The last portion of this tape gives us a more extended
example of the South Carolina Low Country accent.
Just
who
we are you recording so for the four of
you saw the chair here
in Washington we have sort of a nice if we had some more.
You want to read that since
the
call Mockingbird. OK I mean the
market
movers the PERVAN souls upon the plinth phrase that
all of the general leases but bully groups. He still was in
cells or to the root of the what to whom we thought the lone Ismay
of language. Still phenomenal over straight and over
patient plays that phrasing to you and moan in breakup about five pm in
you whatever did or dream this bird could say and
then he
shot bounced airily along the sward twisting where
the maze still missed like her freight and to his hour again.
We science this Lars riddle. Renny plane. How may the death of
that girl in sick be. The life of young fans shakes their own the trees.
You
know have you read some from George Washington cable was
titled to the plus
Giles says you
say things
to Ellison a little he isn't there yet remained a man who did or remembers of
having been to school and having been taught by Stoney hated computing that
the world Israel. For example I thought she this real world is
the cheese to be eaten through and you the nipples quite into
his She's world already at twenty
two he realized this as the out about one Sunday
morning where the intersection of Romeo and curvy streets some seventy years ago.
Formed a certain core of New Orleans.
Yes yes. The trouble was. Was he had been wasteful and honest
he discussed the matter with that fateful friend and confidant Betty's his
yellow body servant they concluded that papa's patient
and him money. Having been no way.
Quite to the run. There were left open only these two
easily enumerated resorts to go to were they sure the
two German majors and they were
to filibustering expedition or else
wanna to trap some games or else competent at twenty
two one must begin to be
something.
That's
very
very particular reader. You
say
don't have anything with you raise me.
Now there isn't and so on him and on the first I have a read of the photo though
I don't know how come out of
this home to look off their
lows across the south plains and Mark yon meeting of the sun and see. Hello.
Take us inside of all the lions or long no longer
we. Now emphases residents smell known as easy
as Pearl dissolved in rosy well and clear path. Dramatic night
great souls. Tis done low lay their hand in
my compost we stars and countless heavens
our glimmer he way in round hell on lies sayin all
night divorce asinine and Scout our Never our lives high
and.
Souls
you recall you were Bush's warriors who are the root of all your support.
Remember when he lies we need to read it again what you
boys
do is
read
before the case.
Or what is abroad in the marsh in the terminals the Somehow in the soul
sing certainly free from the weighing of fate and the same question of things and
by the link then the breath and the sweep of the marshes and
billions marshes. Saccade it is simple and nothing with holding and
free people to shoot yourself in the sky and all for yourselves to
see
tall replay and. That stuff of the sea and the rains and some of
the spray this man like the Catholic man who has my holy
ones God out of knowledge and moves out of infinite pain and side
of blindness and purity out of the
stain as a mark of him secretly built on the warmest So
eyes behold I will build me and they have done the greatness of God I
will fly the greatness of God as the Martian flies in the freedom that fills all
the space tweeks the
Martians by so many rooms as the more stress than them so.
I will hold. And they need a hold on the greatness of
God's Oh light to the greatness of God is the greatest within the range
of the marshes the liberal marshes of
billions and the sea lions large as the marsh low.
Alice is slated the sea for fast food in the town the flood
tide must be looking all the grace of the seed of go about
and about through the intricate channels that flow here and they are
everywhere till his wars have flooded almost creek then the low
lying lanes and the marshes maced with a million
veins that life is with rosy and silver essences low in the Rose
and silver evening
glow Farewell my load on the creek so
low a thousand revelers run to the roofs of the sauce.
The blaze of the marsh breast or passable soaring sound of wings
that westward
were paces and all is still and the currents these two
rows and the sea and the marsh are was just below the plains of
the war as being the town is in his ecstasy that is
that his high height and it is night and now from the vice of the Lord
will the warriors of Lee
Cristo know the less they laugh a fifty
eight that two of the
least
the past.
And then from the baths of the lower will the warmth of
sleep role in them so the millions who will reveal to our waking
can step from the window and the shapes that CRE under the waters
of sleep and I was have could know what women follow
when the tide comes in only link and the breath of the marvelous marshes
of billions.
Has
preceded
this. Place soon to do so so there she will
meet it is them
down windows the common to think is a home.